hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar detecting low abundance proteins
in a Western blot overcoming challenges
for improved signal-to-noise of low
expressing and precious sample targets
I'm Suzy Valdez of lab routes and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about our sponsor please visit them
at WWF Fisher comm now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
best offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker emily hoverter
product manager protein and cell
analysis at Thermo Fisher Scientific for
the complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your steering
emileeh you can now begin your
presentation welcome
thank you for that introduction just to
recap again today we'll be focusing on
the detection of low abundance protein
targets in a Western blot
Western blotting is a powerful and
widely used protein research application
as it allows the full visualization and
characterization of target proteins and
a complex mixture an estimated 5 million
Western blots are performed across the
globe each year which are utilized to
help researchers better understand their
individual approaches of interest and
highly popular areas of study including
drug discovery cancer research and
disease
blotting is often performed downstream
of common protein applications such as
purification protein-protein interaction
mg knockout or gene silencing it can
also be used to determine if proteins
are expressed upregulated or
downregulated in response to external
stimuli
although western blotting is well
understood and very popular it can often
present challenges for certain proteins
of interest in particular the detection
of scarce proteins whether it's a low
abundant target or a low concentration
of sample can be a major challenge and
often results in either faint or
undetectable bands this leads to
repetition or reoptimize in the Western
blot again in this discussion will focus
on different methods and improvements
that can be made to help Western blot
detection of low abundant protein
targets
the Western workflow involved steps from
sample extraction through image capture
and analysis during sample prep the
protea is extracted from the source
whether from a cell a tissue or a sub
cellular fraction once extracted the
protein lysate is loaded onto the gel
and run through protein electrophoresis
to separate out the proteins by
molecular weight the gel is then placed
into a sandwich like structure to
transfer out of the gel and onto a
membrane for immunoblotting detection
Annina blotting includes the washing
blocking antibody probing to detect a
specific target of interest
either chemiluminescence or fluorescence
detection is then used to visualize the
target an imaging system or x-ray film
can be used to then capture this final
image and analyze the results
each year thousands of proteins are
studied and there's been an increasing
need to detect lower amounts of protein
target in the sample
sensitivity is a growing need by many
researchers in Western blotting there
are two primary reasons why sensitivity
may be required the first reason is that
a very low abundant target is being
detected in the Western blot the target
may be low abundant for a variety of
reasons for example the protein
concentration assay may indicate that
the overall protein volume or
concentration was lower than expected
with a lower protein concentration and
if limited sample is available there may
be a need to load smaller amounts of
concentrated protein onto the gel if the
protein load is more dilute a highly
sensitive system may be needed to offset
that limited sample and adequately
detect the specific target
another example is known low abundant
targets usually this knowledge comes
from experimentation or of known
conditions protein such as post
translational modifications drug
inhibition and down regulation can lead
to low Express targets and therefore
require higher sensitivity in detection
finally certain proteins are more
difficult to extract and may result in
lower yields of available protein
membrane bound or nuclear expressed
proteins may be more sticky or stubborn
with during extractions and result in
lower abundant targets in a Western blot
the other reason for sensitivity is to
in order to preserve precious sample the
sample source itself may be limited and
then require efforts to detect those
proteins in a dilute sample certain
tissues such as human or mouse brain
tissue may be available in such limited
quantities that it becomes necessary to
only load a few micrograms onto the gel
additionally a single sample source may
be needed over a variety of experiments
so that sample is therefore spread
across these downstream applications
whatever the individual reason is the
ability to preserve sample loads and
still detect even the
smallest amount of target protein is
critical to making the right research
conclusion in the Western blob
the Western workflow is highlighted here
and again covers six key steps of how to
improve the overall detection of low
abundant targets we'll be covering the
factors that include efficient
extraction and well-prepared protein
samples high quality protein gel
chemistry's for effective protein
separation complete protein transfer
from gel onto the membrane the use of
validated antibodies at optimal
concentrations increased low-end
sensitivity with specialized reagents
and improving the dynamic range and
detection capabilities with new imaging
instrumentation
to improve the detection of low abundant
targets it's important to ensure
efficient protein preparation to
maximize yield and overall recovery of
the protein target there are a variety
of different techniques for cell lysis
all of which work to break down the cell
membrane to extract the protein when
considering the best method of protein
extraction for your experiment it's
critical to think about the sample
source and location of the protein which
you are probing for the sample you are
working with could be mammalian cell or
tissue bacteria yeast insect or plant
within that sample source you may be
extracting from specific locations
including either a membrane-bound
protein such as a cell receptor a
nuclear or a set of salic located
protein wherever your protein is located
it's important to think about using
optimized reagents for that specific
target these reagents should also be
compatible with your downstream
application in this case western
blotting to preserve the protein
activity and function
the table here illustrates the breadth
of reagents that Thermo Fisher
Scientific offers for high quality
efficient and specific protein
extraction
the active ingredient and most of these
lysis reagents are detergents which help
to disrupt the membrane and release the
proteins inside as an example M / which
is listed at the top of this table is
designed for complete cell lysis and
contains a mild non - naturing detergent
that dissolve cell membranes to extract
and soluble eyes toll protein from
cellular compartments to help ensure
efficacy for research needs we've
validated Emporer for use with several
cell lines including primary suspension
and adherent cell types as well as
validation for Western blot applications
homogenous and efficient tissue protein
extraction can be challenging due to the
variety of different tissue compositions
fibers tissues such as heart or kidney
cannot be effectively extracted through
freeze thaw or manual methods without
the aid of a detergent
conversely soft tissues like spleen or
liver require a milder extraction
protocol for optimal results to help
improve the overall extraction of tissue
samples cheaper also listed on this
table was designed and developed using a
mild detergent that enhances the
solubilization of proteins without
compromising their function and the
neutral pH and salt concentration of
this reagent enable more efficient
extraction from cell compartments to
yield homogeneous lysate
while many of the reagents listed here
can be used to better optimize
extraction whose specific sample type
and location there are still several
several proteins that are not easily
extracted in efficient extraction and
low yield can present difficulties in
detecting during the Western blot
application
one such class of proteins that present
inherent difficulties our plasma
membranes called g-protein coupled
receptors these gpcrs are key to cell
function as they play a primary role in
transmitting signals across the cell
membrane they are the largest class of
membrane proteins with greater than 1000
identified and are a major drug target
for genetic and immune system disorders
one of the major challenges in GPC our
research is the ability to efficiently
extract the receptors from the membrane
without compromising their structure and
functional integrity in addition GPCRs
have poor cellular solubility due to
their hydrophobicity and are expressed
at much lower levels compared to
intracellular proteins they often
require enrichment prior to downstream
analysis
as mentioned gpcrs are difficult to
extract which often lead to harsher
conditions that result in either
denatured or unstable proteins at lower
yields they usually require further
enrichment and stabilization of the
target traditional protocols often use
high salt or high pH buffers to
disassociate the proteins from the cell
membrane but this risks damage to the
protein integrity traditional methods
are also laborious time-consuming and
require expensive equipment
to address these concerns and issues we
recently introduced the Pierce gpcr
extraction and stabilization reagent in
all-in-one solution to efficiently
extract and stabilize gpcrs in
conjunction the reagents utilize a
proprietary detergent solution where the
sample is first harvested washed and
then pelleted the gpcrs are extracted
during using the gpcr extraction and
stabilization reagent followed by
centrifugation the resulting whole cell
lysate contains soluble eyes and
stabilized receptor proteins the region
has been tested for use with endogenous
and overexpressed GPCRs and receptor
function has been verified by receptor
ligand binding assays
in the data shown here we can see the
efficient extraction and sellable
ization of GPCRs from both cells and
tissues using this new gpcr extraction
and stabilization reagent these are
highlighted in column C in both examples
the data compares this new product to
the mill aport transmembrane protein
extraction kit buffers a and buffer B
and to Ripa buffer which is listed in
column D to perform this experiment
three GPCRs listed along the left hand
side were solubilized from HeLa HEK 293
and mouse liver cells using the four
different methods
the extracts were separated transferred
and detected using super signal
substrates and the images were captured
using the eye bright FL 1000 imaging
system the gpcr extraction and
stabilization reagent demonstrates
improved banding and yield in the
soluble fraction labeled s when compared
to the insoluble pellet labeled P in
both cells and tissue extracts using
reagents like this can help better
extract those target proteins for
efficient detection in western blotting
applications
moving into the next step of the Western
blot workflow it's important to choose
an appropriate gel chemistry based on
the molecular weight of the target and
the expected load volume of the sample
Kjell chemistry's have been talked more
and more as a key decision factor in
optimal protein separation
there are a variety of jal options
available and it can often be
overwhelming or even confusing to know
which jal chemistry is the best one to
use when focusing on low abundant
targets specifically fist rizz gels can
be an effective tool for proteins of low
abundance or for proteins with post
translational modifications fists wrist
gels help to provide improved band
separation and overall protection
quality first off is Tris can help
preserve the protein integrity within
the sample the neutral pH chemistry of
the gel minimizes pretty modifications
or degradation that can cause poor band
resolution the result can be seen in the
image to the right in this example the
bulb is Tris gel shows the preservation
of these full-length proteins listed
across the top while the Tris glycine
gel from bio-rad shows multiple low
molecular weight decorative protein
fragments in addition biz portrays
chemistry's can help achieve superior
band quality as they are designed to
provide sharper straighter bands while
we focus on biz TRIZ gels for detection
of low abundance targets trip lysine
gels which are a popular chemistry to be
used are certainly useful for detection
of high abundant and broad range
molecular protein targets
detection of proteins whether low or
high abundance is most efficient clean
and optimal when the protein target is
resolved in the middle portion of the
gel if your target is either high or low
molecular weight a broad range Ellis
typically not effective at resolving
these unique targets to address these
concerns we suggest using the TRIZ
acetate chemistry for high molecular
weight targets and tracing for low
molecular weight these two chemistries
are independently optimized to provide
better separation for their given
targets and the image on the left we can
see the sensitivity improvements of the
EGF receptor protein when using a TRIZ
acetate gel compared to a broad range
Tris glycine gel the three to eight
percent triz acetate chemistry provides
a matrix to allow larger molecule irwe
proteins to travel more effectively and
separate for improved Manor detection
conversely the 16% try some chemistry
slows the migrations that low molecular
weight proteins or peptides which
typically travel very rapidly through a
gel are better resolved this can be seen
on the left-hand side of the gel of the
slide ion concentrations are also
significantly higher at the bottom of a
gel and when used with low molecular
weight proteins can cause
disproportionately high current and
transfer leading to blow through try
steam gels keep these low molecular rate
targets closer to the middle of the gel
to reduce the risk of this blow through
happening
the examples shown with try scene gels
compared to Tris glycine gels separates
and attacks the cleaved caspase-3 shown
on the right
the traicee and gel is effective at
separating out these two fragments of
the target for better detection and
sensitivity
regardless of the chemistry used in your
Western blot it's critical to also
consider the effect of protein load
volumes if you see poor resolution or
Lane streaking this can be a result of
too much protein on the gel as a general
guideline the maximum recommended sample
load on the mini gel is between 10 and
15 micrograms of lysate per Lane when
looking at low abundance targets it's
not uncommon to to instinctly think that
loading more protein will lead to higher
probability of detection
however this intuition is normal but can
actually jeopardize the quality of the
blood and lead to suboptimal detection
while protein concentration is key to
good band resolution there are many
instances where the overall
concentration may actually be very low
either because the low yield of
extraction or because the sample is
precious and must be preserved in these
instances when dilute sample is required
a higher volume is needed to be loaded
on the gel to get adequate detection the
wedge well gel format allows greater
overall volume of dilute samples to be
accommodated without the spillover to
neighboring wells and the images below
we show trace glycine and biz trees
wedge wall formats compared to bio-rad
gels in both of these cases we can see
that loading up to sixty microliters of
volume in the wedge well gel format does
not have protein spillover or band
smiling in the lanes compared to the non
wedge film formats
which well gels are available in a
variety of gel chemistry's and again are
ideal for loading high volumes of dilute
samples in the detection of low abundant
targets
moving to transfer will now cover some
key tips for ensuring complete protein
transfer from the jowls to the membrane
to briefly review the transfer step we
can see the key format used in the
schematic at the left transfer involves
running a current through the gel
membrane sandwich to move the proteins
out of the gel and onto the membrane a
membrane is often used for detection as
a stronger support compared to delicate
gels and provides a surface on which
proteins are more easily accessible
during the transfer
the SDS found negatively charged
proteins migrate out of the gel and
towards the positive anode the membrane
sits next to the gel and binds the
proteins as they moved Gel chemistries
and transfer methods both play critical
roles in the quality of the overall
transfer
focusing first on the gel chemistry we
can see in the image on the right
how biz Tris gels compared to triskele
Ising gels when it comes to track
transfer efficiency and detection
sensitivity in these examples
a43 one cell lysate extracts were
electrophorus and used on either the
both distres or Tris glycine gel both
gel types were then transferred using
the eye blot to from Invitrogen onto
either nitro cellulous
or PVDF membranes and then probed to the
faso EGF receptor mouse monoclonal
antibody followed by an anti mouse
HRP secondary i detected with ECL the
biz trees gel shows greater overall
intensity and additional band detection
at the low end illustrating the higher
and more complete protein transfer out
of the gel and onto the membrane
another important factor during transfer
is the method and protocol used
traditional wet tank transfer can
provide high efficiency and is the
widest used method it relies on
traditional tank formats with use of
Tobin transfer buffers and manually
setting up the transfer sandwich using
an assortment of available membranes and
filter papers while watching transfer
continues to be a very popular choice
for many researchers there are some
downsides to this method including the
use and disposal of hazardous methanol
based buffers longer amounts of time
needed to complete the transfer and
performance risks such as blow through
or uneven transfer newer transfer
systems have been developed to maintain
and optimize transfer conditions while a
drastically improving the time of
transfer to less than 10 minutes
not only is convenience improved but
overall quality of the transfer can also
be improved this is critical when
detecting low abundant proteins as dead
spots blow through and complete transfer
or blood supply inconsistencies can
result in inconclusive results the in
beiträge and fast transfer systems which
include our eye blot 2 and power blotter
devices those come with ready to use
stacks that offer performance advantages
over traditional do-it-yourself stacks
shown in the data here is a comparison
of the ready-to-use stacks against a
traditional self-assembled stack
traditional stacks can lead to
efficiency and reproducibility
inconsistencies resulting from uneven
hydration of the membrane insufficient
removal of the buffers or stack miss
handling using too many or too few
filter papers incorrect stack
orientation drying of stacks or
contaminated buffers in the
do-it-yourself stacks can cause problems
using preassembled stacks with either
the eye blot 2 or power blotter can help
eliminate the risk of these issues from
occurring
in addition to improving the transfer
consistency fast transfer devices can
also help improve sensitivity while
adequate transfer is possible across all
transfer systems it's often necessary to
optimize and ensure good transfer on the
system of choice buffers membrane types
and membrane binding capacities all
played a role in affecting the transfer
quality in a given system and the data
on the left a lysate was loaded at
decreasing levels to determine transfer
efficiency across a range of
concentrations we can see an improved
transfer at the low end of the lycée
dilution range when we use the semi-dry
power bladder system on the right
compared to wet tank transfer this is
largely due to the optimized reagents
and the optimized running program on the
system on top of the performance
benefits the transfer using semi-dry
power plotter was accomplished in seven
minutes compared to a full hour using
wet tank
once the transfer is complete the immuno
blotting and processing steps begin
we'll start by discussing the importance
of using validated antibodies to
increase the sensitivity and quality for
low abundant targets at Thermo Fisher
Scientific we provide a large portfolio
of available primary antibodies across
thousands of target proteins as well as
a variety of secondary antibodies with
either enzyme or fluorescent labels for
Western blot detection on top of the
high quality robust portfolio offering
we provide validation and guarantee the
performance of these antibodies in
specific applications in all western by
experience experiments but in particular
when the protein of interest may be more
difficult to detect or lower abundant
using a validated high quality antibody
is essential to maximize the quality of
the result the affinity of the primary
for the target and its validated used in
the specific asset application are both
important considerations
with the antibody of choice proper
dilution should always be considered
depending on the starting concentration
of the antibody and the anticipated
substrate that will be used in a Western
where higher sensitivity is required
it's common to consider using a higher
concentration of antibody in an attempt
to increase the sensitivity however high
concentrations do not always mean better
results in fact for low abundant targets
it is strongly recommended to use a
higher sensitivity substrate and further
dilute the primary and secondary
antibodies to much primary or secondary
when used with these high sensitivity
substrates can over saturate the blot or
cause excessive background noise these
problems that get very difficult to
effectively detect the target and make
inclusive decisions on the data analysis
for primaries a 1 to 1000 to 1 to 5000
dilutions from a starting one big per
mil stock is a very typical first pass
however if the blot is too saturated or
not enough detection is acquired the
blot can be stripped and reproved with a
higher resolution of secondary of excuse
me primary antibody for secondary
antibodies it is highly useful to factor
in the substrate of choice when
determining the appropriate dilution
again with low abundant targets a high
sensitivity substrate should be used
these substrates are designed to give
higher light immittance from the HRP
enzyme label compared to standard or
routine ECL substrates when using these
specialized substrate reagents a higher
dilution of antibodies should be used so
as to prevent over saturation of the
blot
instead of using a typical one to five
thousand or one to 10,000 secondary a
one to 100,000 or even up to one to two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars of
secondary can be prepared the data shown
in the middle of this slide illustrates
oversaturation and optimal saturation in
a Western blot too much signal as seen
on the top western makes it difficult to
analyze quantitate or make conclusions
this often is the result when too much
antibody is being used on the blot
conversely when properly diluted and
optimized the bottom blot shows a much
easier to analyze westerns of across
varying load conditions
in addition to using validated
antibodies at optimal dilutions using
detection reagents specifically designed
to increase sensitivity can help improve
detection of low abundance targets
chemiluminescence substrates continue to
be the most commonly used detection
method for Western blotting due to their
flexibility across film and imaging
systems and the ability to provide
higher levels of sensitivity however low
abundant targets can still result the
detection challenges if the right
substrate and optimizations aren't
incorporated common problems include
weak or no signal poor signal-to-noise
or wasted sample and reagents if
repetition is required these challenges
are most often experienced when working
with low abundant targets in those
instances using high sensitivity
substrates can greatly increase the
chance of adequate signal
Thermo Fisher Scientific most recently
introduced an improved high sensitivity
substrate that provides the greater
levels of detection sensitivity
the super signal West adil substrate
provides ultimate detection sensitivity
designed specifically for detecting very
dilute or low abundant targets
it can provide over three times greater
sensitivity than other conventional high
sensitivity substrates and detects
proteins ro routine substrates fall
short further it has the greatest level
of signal-to-noise to allow users to
visualize bands for previously they were
undetectable an example of this
advantage is shown in the two western
blot examples in the top right corner
super signal West a doe presents a
unique value and allowing users to also
save on their sample or antibodies we'll
cover these attributes and greater depth
in the following two slides
this data comparison we can see how
super signal West Adele compares to
other substrates that are marketed for
high sensitivity Western blots in the
blossom graph shown heel l isis for
serial diluted and loaded at the
indicated volumes all blots are
transferred and probed for a katy and
captured on the eye bright imager at the
same exposure time when we compare using
super signal West at O two substrates
provided by bio-rad GE or Milla poor we
can see the increased overall intensity
and smell above background advantages
that super signal West a doe can provide
this signal is especially important in
Western blots looking to detect very low
amounts of target protein or very dilute
samples to further illustrate how super
signal West a doe can help preserve
precious sample we can look at the case
study here in this experiment we can
compare super signal West a doe to
routine substrates from bio-rad and
milla poor routine substrates are often
used for medium to high abundant protein
targets or routine Western blots however
even if a protein target is medium to
high abundant the sample itself may be
precious and requires as much
conservation as possible sample such as
tissues or human cell extracts may be
very limited and availability or again
used across several experiments so each
microgram is used is considered precious
if routine substrates are typically used
this usually requires higher loads
upwards of 10 to 20 micrograms to get
the detectable signal that's needed this
is illustrated in the yellow and blue
boxes and corresponding charts however
supers in the West a dough can be used
in replacement of routine substrates to
help preserve sample and in fact load up
to 1/16 of the amount compared to
routine substrates and produce the same
signal detection this is illustrated by
the red box and corresponding chart when
samples are so precious and only a
couple of micrograms or less are
available through personal West's adult
can provide confidence in obtaining
adequate detection sensitivity in these
cases
additional reagents to improve signal
detection include blocking buffers when
porous signal-to-noise is obtained on a
Western block a contributing factor is
often the blocking buffer used while dry
milk is a common choice and worked for
many Western blot needs this blocking
buffer contains a variety of proteins
that are not well defined or controlled
and can lead to non uniform and
suboptimal blocking efficiency using a
purified blocking buffer like the thermo
Fisher Scientific peers clear valve
blocker or starting block blocking
buffer can help improve the
signal-to-noise and enhance the
sensitivity in your Western blot an
example of this low end detection
improvement is illustrated in the
Western blot shown at the right all
three of these Western blots contain
equivalent serial dilutions of Gila
lysate once transferred the blots were
blocked with the respective blocking
buffers starting black clear milk or by
percent nonfat milk
they were then simultaneously probed for
Iraq one and bcl-xl supers in the West
auto substrate was used to detect the
low levels of protein targets on all
three blots as demonstrated starting
block provides the greatest level of
sensitivity and overall signal to noise
improvement followed by the Pierce clear
milk nonfat dry milk reduces the overall
signal intensity and is not able to
provide detectable signal to the same
sensitivity level as the other blocking
buffers used
when ultimate sensitivity is required it
can be very helpful to use specialized
blocking buffers like starting black
designed to increase sensitivity and
signal-to-noise
a unique and exceptional tool personal
enhancement is the super signal Western
blot enhancer which is used to help
enhance the detection of low abundant or
weakly immunoreactive antigens by
increasing sensitivity up to tenfold the
super signal Western blot enhancer is an
innovative technology that works to
increase the specific binding of the
primary antibody to the target protein
while also reducing the overall
background of the BLA the reagent is a
two-part system first containing a
membrane treatment that helps to
decrease the background and nonspecific
binding sites
the secondary agent works as a primary
antibody diluent to increase the
exposure of the antibody epitope binding
sites and promote effective targeted
binding to the protein of interest this
improved specificity is especially
important for poor quality or low
affinity antibodies the overall result
using the enhancer is a cleaner more
sensitive Western blot detection as
illustrated in the blot on the right
hand side
when using this do personal Western blot
enhancer detection sensitivity can be
increased up to tenfold and the overall
signal above background is greatly
enhanced
to the last step of the Western workflow
we end at the image capture and analysis
step using modern technologies such as
CCD imaging systems can greatly improve
dynamic range and low-end detection
the to imaging modes most commonly used
in Western blotting are either film or
CCD cameras film capture is the
traditional method while relatively
straightforward it prevents its
challenges as optimal exposure times may
be more difficult to obtain and require
repetition darkrooms can be expensive
and more difficult to maintain
conversely CSV imaging is a fast-growing
technology that is being used more
widely and adopted by Western blot
researchers it is a modern technology
that can be used across a broad range of
applications including both
chemiluminescent and fluorescent Western
blotting DNA gel scanning and protein
gel staining the instrument and software
enabled easier data acquisition and
optimal exposures as they use smart
features to predict the best exposure
times for the light that is being
generated on the blot however these
imagers do require an investment
training and a designated space within
the lab despite these factors many
research labs are finding significant
value in CCD imaging systems
the invented eyebright imaging system is
a technically advanced yet easy to use
system for Western blots it enables a
broad range of capabilities for Western
blotting protein gels and DNA gels and
contains a powerful camera for high
resolution images the innovative smart
interface makes it an easily adaptable
platform that brings the benefits of
imaging systems without excessive
training
one of the biggest benefits to cease to
be imaging is the expand dynamic range
and the improved image capture CCD
imaging allows them allows for multiple
images to be taken and stored so it's
easier to achieve the optimal exposure
time the first try in the eye braid
system the camera uses a smart exposure
feature which helps to predict the best
exposure time for the blonde the data
here shows lots for three different
targets and at 10 second exposures each
of the eye bright imaging system or
traditional film are used to capture the
image when using film the block over
saturates at the top and very quickly
compared to the eye bright imager in
addition the eye braid is able to
maintain the low-end sensitivity and
provide a linear detectable range far
greater than film which is shown in the
graph to the right
you
supporting data of the signal linearity
generated with eyebright is shown here
while Western blots image with x-ray
film may appear to have a linear
detectable range when performing
densitometry on the individual bands
it's clear to see that the signal
captured on film has a much narrower
dynamic range compared to signal
captured with the eyebright imaging
system images acquired on the eye bright
show a linear detection range for PDI
from 125 nanograms up to 1500 nanograms
of hilo lysate whereas with the film the
linear signal is only from 125 nanograms
to 500 nanograms
three of today's review we covered a
variety of techniques and products that
can help improve signal detection and
sensitivity of low abundant targets
across the Western workflow these
considerations include efficient protein
extraction and optimized target specific
reagents use of gel chemistries that
improve protein separation and preserve
protein integrity complete and efficient
transfers through the use of optimized
gels and transfer methods ensuring the
use of validated antibodies specific for
Western blotting incorporating high
sensitivity detection reagents such as
super signal West at O and super signal
western blot enhancer and the use of CCD
imaging systems for improved dynamic
range and image exposure western
blotting is a highly popular technique
and an essential research tool for
protein studies we hope these tools can
be useful in your Western blot
optimization and troubleshooting to
achieve successful and efficient western
blots particularly for low abundant
targets
I'll not open up for any questions
Thank You Emily for that informative
presentation and we will now start the
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
our first question Emily for audience
member is if a routine ECL substrate is
used first and no bands are seen can the
super signal a dope substrate be used
directly after or is stripping and
reprogram probing necessary so that's a
great question typically if you're using
an ECL substrate and you're not seeing
any bands we would recommend stripping
off the antibody so using a stripping
something like a restore shipping buffer
to remove those antibodies and the
reason for that is because the
antibodies may not be fully optimized
for the higher sensitivity substrate
it's best to remove those in and
reoptimize that being said we do know
quite a few customers I'm prefer to move
up the line of substrates if you will so
if ECL doesn't show a detection they may
add a stronger sensitivity substrate so
you can you can certainly try this and
then once you're able to detect that
signal it is best to then strip and then
reoptimize using properly dye suited
antibody concentrations
thank you and Emily can long film
exposures be used to increase
sensitivity when bands are not
detectable so exposure time is a great
way to influence the the sensitivity and
many researchers do use varying exposure
times to help increase that sentence
sensitivity so when you're using film
yes you can certainly expose for a
longer time the caveat is often that
longer exposure times can start to
increase the background but but they can
help get that signal detected so whether
you're using film or even an imaging
system like the eye bright imager a
longer exposure time can can be useful
again the nice thing with eye bright
imaging systems is that that smart
exposure feature can be used to help
predict the optimal exposure time so it
may help you predict that fifteen or
thirty minute or even longer exposure to
get the sensitivity of your particular
western blot thank you for that and I
want to also thank our audience members
for their great questions coming in our
next question from an audience is if
using higher sensitivity substrate in a
system where nonspecific bands are
detected won't that non specific
detection increase significantly as well
so nonspecific bands are certainly
problematic for a lot of researchers in
theory yes if you're having issues with
with nonspecific bands increase in the
sensitivity that signal overall on the
Western blot is going to also be
increased so what I would suggest if if
nonspecific bands are our problem
there's a couple of things to look at
the first is definitely be the primary
antibody so if the antibody that you're
using is
less specific to the target considering
a different antibody and especially an
antibody that's validated for Western
blotting would be the first first step
to evaluate the other product and you
can use that we discussed today is that
super signal Western blot enhancer and
again what that enhancer reagent does is
it's a two-part system and and the
second reagent that's used is an
antibody diluent and that bill youant
helps to increase the specific binding
and the efficacy of the antibody to
target binding and so can actually help
reduce nonspecific binding in the system
so a combination of looking at the
primary antibody using one that's
validated and very specific for for the
target and potentially incorporating an
additional reagent like the enhancer
reagent can help reduce that nonspecific
binding so that your sensitivity which
which you might need to be improved is
approved improved only for your specific
target
thank you for that now how can you
increase sensitivity of
chemiluminescence lots that are stripped
and re probed so with stripping and rape
robing the key there is to fully remove
the antibodies that that were used for
immunoblotting in the first detection so
we have two reagents that are used for
stripping and robing and those reagents
are restore and restore plus to get the
best sensitivity of both targets
specifically if you're using antibodies
that are very specific for the target
the restore plus is a great reagent to
use because restore Plus is designed to
fully remove antibodies especially
antibodies that are very specific to the
target and therefore very tightly bound
on the membrane so if you use restore
plus that reagent can help fully remove
and strip away the antibodies that were
used in the first detection and then re
probe with the new set of antibodies for
the other target or targets so we're
using restore plus is a great way to
increase the sensitivity during that
stripping and repro being process
thank you and Emily how about Simcoe and
picot how sensitive are they compared to
a doe so that's a great question and it
sounds like very familiar with the
Souper signal substrate so the super
signal Pico or P Co plus is really
designed to be more of a routine ECL
substrate so better used when you're a
target is either medium or high abundant
and you have plenty of sample to load
onto the to the gel femto is also a high
sensitivity substrate when compared to
West at Oh super signal West a doe is
going to be even more sensitive than
femto again by about three-fold more
sensitive so using West a doe it comes
to be very important when that sample
availability is very low so if you only
have a couple of micrograms whilst a doe
is going to be able to do even a better
job then super signal West femto is in
detecting those those targets so so West
femto if you're using that today that is
continued to be available but if you
need even more sensitivity or if you
have a limited sample to load onto the
gel the new super signal a doe can be
used to increase that sensitivity even
more than than femto
Thank You Emily and thank you for your
time today and your important research
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience today well I
just want to say I appreciate everyone's
time to listen into this webinar we
certainly hope to continue to be a
support here at Thermo Fisher Scientific
for four research needs and we look
forward to any other questions that come
in even after this webinar we will
certainly reach out and support any
further needs so thank you very much and
thank you again and we'd like to also
thank lab roots and our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast and before
we go I want to remind the audience
thanks and thank them for joining us
today and also for your interesting
questions like Emily said questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period we
will address them through the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration labrys will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time bye bye